human origins who are we where do we
come from and how do we know in my field
paleoanthropology we explore human
origins the who and where questions by
analyzing fossils that date back
thousands and even millions of years in
2015 a team of colleagues and I named a
new species in the genus Homo our genus
Homo Naledi let's take a step back and
put that into context the last common
ancestors between humans and chimps did
somewhere between six and eight million
years the earliest hominins or earliest
human ancestors evolved you know group
known as the australopithecines the
australopithecines evolved in the genus
Homo and eventually modern humans us
with each new fossil discovery we get a
little bit closer to better
understanding who we are and where we
came from
with these new fossil finds we realize
we now have to make changes to this tree
until this discovery we thought we had a
pretty good idea about the patterns of
evolutionary change current fossil
evidence suggests that the earliest
populations of the genus Homo evolved in
Africa somewhere between two and three
million years fast forward to
approximately three hundred thousand
years to have receive the origins of
first modern humans while the fossil
record between these timeframes in
Africa is relatively sparse the fossils
nonetheless demonstrated certain trends
from our earliest ancestors to modern
humans for example our brains were
becoming larger relative to the rest of
our body our pelvis were becoming more
Bowl shape and our hand wrists
morphology or form suggested a change in
our grip as we began to make and use
stone tools and spend less time in the
trees these new fossils disrupt
everything we thought we knew about
these trends
and forced us to change the way that we
think about human evolution South Africa
in general but the cradle humankind in
particular contains numerous sites where
hundreds of thousands of fossils have
been found as an undergraduate student I
fell in love with one of them
mrs. plez the skull of a 2.1 million
year old early human ancestor from that
point on I was determined to go to South
Africa and study human evolution I first
traveled there in 2003 and I did get to
go see my beloved mrs. plez but words
can hardly convey my excitement when I
was chosen as an early career scientist
by Lee burger a world-renowned
paleoanthropologists to be one of the
primary analysts of recently excavated
unpublished fossils this treasure trove
of fossils was being recovered from a
new site called the den elated chamber
in the rising star cave system species
are often named based on a skull a lower
jaw or very rarely a handful of post
cranial or below the neck elements the
fossils from dental ad were another
story all together in unprecedented
approximately 1,800 specimens so far had
been excavated from the rising star
system representing at least 15
individual skeletons the research team
that I was invited to join was tasked
with describing comparing and analyzing
the fossils with the difficult goal of
identifying - what species the fossils
belonged we were divided up into our
different areas of expertise we're
divided up in different areas of the lab
- so there was hand land for the fossil
hand people hip heaven for the pelvis I
was in the tooth booth
and after long intense days in the lab
the different teams would meet up at
night and discuss our findings still
consumed by questions from our analyses
it was incredible how different the
interpretations were each body part
seemed to come from a different species
based on what we knew from the fossil
record the suite of characteristics we
were seeing didn't match any known
species and if we had only recovered the
skull we might have called it one thing
if we'd only recovered the pelvis we
might have called it another the anatomy
of the skeletons didn't make sense with
the framework of what we thought we knew
of human evolution did it belong in the
genus Homo
should it be an Australopithecus een
those bipedal more ape-like ancestors or
perhaps it should be in its own species
ultimately after much deliberation we
decided the rising star specimens did
indeed warrant a new species which we
called homo Naledi from the head to the
feet the fossils present a mosaic of
primitive or ancestral and derived a
more modern like features this goal
obscure is quite derived appearing most
similar to early representatives of the
genus Homo like Homo habilis and Homo
erectus
however the brain is scarcely half the
size of a modern human one one that is
smaller than any other early homo that
has ever been found as someone who
studies teeth I might argue these are
the coolest fossils found at the site
these sandwich consists of a hundred and
ninety holder fragmentary teeth that
range in age from very old to very young
like the skeletons the teeth present a
mix of primitive and derived traits in
modern humans the third molar is
typically the smallest while the first
molar is the biggest but Homo Naledi has
the primitive condition where the third
molar is the biggest and the first molar
is the smallest the anterior teeth or
the incisors and canines are small for
the genus Homo and the lower canine has
a cusp you lid on it an extra cusp all
that gives it a distinct mitten like
shape
that shares with some specimens of the
early home human Homo erectus the
overall shape of the teeth looked odd to
me
so I performed crown shape analysis on
the clues the surfaces of deciduous
teeth or baby teeth on your left and the
permanent premolars and molars on your
right the deciduous teeth are especially
narrow and the premolars are unique in
their outline shape compared to other
hominids in fact when I compare the
outlines when I lay them on top of each
other they look very similar we say they
have low intraspecific variations for
the variation within the species is low
when I compare this groups like the
australopithecines the intraspecific
variation is much larger post cranial II
the team concluded that the position of
the shoulders suggesting the letti was a
climber the flared pelvis and curved
fingers are all primitive for the genus
Homo on the other hand the human-like
wrist long slender legs and modern feet
are all consistent with other members of
the genus in 2017 we announced more
specimens of Homo Naledi from the nearby
Lacetti chamber also in the rising star
cave system in addition our geology team
managed to produce an age estimate the
dates a big deal because up until now we
had based our analysis solely on the
morphology of the specimens without
previous knowledge of how old something
is something which could unconsciously
bias our interpretations with this small
brain and flared pelvis we would not
have been surprised if the fossils
turned out to be two million years old
instead the fossils dated to two hundred
and thirty five to three hundred thirty
six thousand years an incredibly young
date for such a small brain individual
so think back to what I said earlier we
thought that our brains were becoming
larger relative to the rest of our body
now we have a small brain young
individual complicating this idea what
does all this mean
homo Naledi has taught us that we need
to reassess what it means to be in the
genus Homo we need to rethink what it
means to be human in fact most of the
characteristics that we use to define
the genus Homo such as brain size and
hip morphology are no longer valid no
other species exists with this mix of
primitive and drive traits why is there
so much morphological variation than
genus homo and what force is driving
that variation another implication for
these fossils is that for the first time
we have concrete evidence of a species
coexisting in Africa at 300,000 years
with modern humans until its discovery
we only had modern humans large brain
modern humans that existed in Africa did
they interbreed with each other
did they compete with each other another
implication that these fossils have is
for the archaeologists studying stone
tools in South Africa keep in mind that
neither the dental lady nor the Lacetti
chambers have any artifacts in them
however they do overlap in time with
several stone tool industries the makers
of which are considered to be either
modern humans or direct human ancestors
this begs the question who made the
stone tools of South Africa marine
science has historically played a key
role in identifying a species as a tool
user the ideas that you need to have a
large brain to have even the capacity to
make stone tools but that notion has
been questioned furthermore homo Naledi
even with the small brain size has a
hand risk morphology similar to other
species that did make and new stone
tools suggesting it had the capability
with two species coexisting in Africa at
300,000 years we can no longer assume we
know the maker of tools at know so with
at sites with no associated species so
where does home and let he fit in our
human evolutionary lineage who was a
more closely related to who does it
evolved from we're still trying to
figure all that out it's ironic because
paleoanthropologist arena
for having small sample sizes we now
have a large sample size and more
questions than answers homo Naledi has
taught us has brought us a little bit
closer to better understanding our
evolutionary past
so while mrs. plez will always hold a
special place in my heart she now shares
that space with several thousand others
thank you
[Applause]